my name is Paul Nicklin then I'm a
contributing photographer for National
Geographic magazine I wanted to go down
to Antarctica and get in the water with
his many leopard seals as I could we
pulled up in the zodiac and we saw this
massive leopard seal my guide Yunnan has
a lot of experience with them said
bloody hell that's the biggest leopard
seal I've ever seen time to get in the
water yacht
I slipped into the water terrified of
what might happen and I swam up to this
leopard seal my legs were shaking and I
had dry mouth and right away she dropped
the penguin she came up to me and she
opened her mouth and her heads twice as
wide as a grizzly bears head she's huge
she took my whole head and camera inside
her mouth and did these threat displays
but then the most amazing thing happened
she went off and got me a live penguin
she came up and she started to feed me a
penguin
and she kept letting these live penguins
go and the penguin would shoot past me
and she would look disgusted as she'd go
by me she did this over and over and
then I think she realized that I was
this useless predator in her ocean
probably gonna starve to death and I
think she became quite panic and she
started to bring me weak penguins then
dead penguins then she showed me how to
eat the penguin she would offer me
partially consumed angles she started to
take penguins and actually push them
into my camera I think she thought the
camera was my mouth which is every
photographer's dream this went on for
four days so here I came to Antarctica
to photograph this potentially vicious
animal to have this predator this top
predator in Antarctica take care of me
and nurture me and feed me for four days
straight it was the most incredible
experience I've ever had at the National
Geographic photographer
you